can you explain the origin of each of
these marxism
and nazism
in a kind of way that we have been
talking about the formation of ideas
hegel is to protestantism what thomas
aquinas is to catholicism he he was like
the philosopher who took
german protestantism
and
and also kant and ficta and shelling and
he built
a philosophical system
he explicitly said this by the way he
wanted to bridge
between philosophy and religion he
explicitly said that i'm not i'm not
voicing that on him he said it
repeatedly in many different places so
he was trying to create a philosophical
system
that
gathered to it
i think the core mythos
of christianity the core mythos of
christianity is this idea of a narrative
structure to reality in which progress
is real in which our actions now
can change the future we can
co-participate with god in the creation
of the future and that future can be
better it can reach something like a
utopia or the promised land or whatever
he created a philosophical system of
brilliance by the way he's a genius but
basically what it did was it it took
that religious vision and gave it the
air of philosophical
intelligibility and respect
and then marx takes that and says you
know that process of the by which the
narrative is working itself out that
hegel called dialectic i don't think
it's primarily happening in ideas i
think it's happening primarily in
between classes within socioeconomic
factors but it's the same story here's
this mechanism of history it's
technological it's going to move this
way
it can move towards a utopia we can
either
participate in furthering it
like participating in the work of god or
we can thwart it and be against it and
so you have a you have a
pseudo-religious vision it's all
encompassing think about how marxism is
not just a philosophical position it's
not just an economic position it's an
entire worldview an entire account of
of history and and a a demanding account
of what human excellence is and it has
all these things about participating
belonging fitting to
but it's very uh in
in marx's case it's very
uh pragmatic or or
directly applicable to society to where
it leads to
it more naturally leads to political
ideologies it does
but i think marks to very significant
degree inherits one of hegel's main
flaws
hegel is talking about all this and he's
trying to fit it into
right post kantian philosophy so for him
it's ultimately you know propositional
conceptual
he
like everybody after descartes is very
focused on the propositional level and
he's not
paying deep attention to
the non-propositional this is why the
two great critics
of hegel
nietzsche and kirkegaard they're trying
to put their finger
on the non-propositional the
non-conceptual the will to power or
faith in and they're trying to bring out
all these other kinds of knowing as
being inadequate that's why kirkegaard
met when he said hegel made a system and
then he sat down beside it
right um and and and so
marxism is very much
it is activists it's about reorganizing
society but the the transformation in
individuals is largely ideological
meaning it's largely about
these significant propositional changes
and adopting a set of beliefs when it
came in contact with the soviet union or
with the what became the soviet union
why do you think it had such a powerful
hold on such a large number of people
not marxism but implementation of
marxism in the name of communism
because it offered people
i mean
it offered people something that
typically only religions had offered and
it offered people the hope of making a
new man a new kind of human being in a
new world
and when you've been living in russia
in which things seem to be locked
in a system that is crushing most people
getting the promise
in the air of scientific legitimacy
that we can make new human beings and a
new world
and in which
happiness will ensue that's an
intoxicating proposal you get sort of
like i said you get
you get all of the intoxication of a
religious utopia but you get all the
seeming legitimacy of claiming that it's
a scientific
understanding of history and economics
it's very popular to criticize communism
marxism these days
and
i often put myself in the place before
any of the implementations came to be
i i tried to think if i would be able to
predict
what the implementations of marxism and
communism would result in in the 20th
century and i'm not sure
i'm smart enough to make that prediction
because at the core of the ideas are
respecting
it's uh with marx it's very economics
type theory so it's basically respecting
the value of the worker
and the regular man in society for for
making a contribution to that society
and to me that seems like a powerful
idea
and it's not clear to me how it goes
wrong
in fact it's still not clear to me
why the hell did this like with stalin
happen or mile happen it's there's
something very interesting and complex
about human nature in hierarchies about
distributed cognition that results in
that and it's not trivial to understand
no no
so i i mean i wonder if you can put a
finger on it why like why did it go so
so wrong so i think uh you know what
ohana talks about in uh
the intellectual history of modernity um
talks about
the the promethean spirit
the idea
the really
radical proposal
and think about how it's
not so radical to us and in that sense
marxism has succeeded the radical
proposal that you see even in the french
revolution
and don't forget the terror comes in the
french revolution too
that we can make ourselves into god-like
beings think of the hubris in that
right and think of the overconfidence to
think
that we so understand human nature and
all of its complexities and human
history
right and how religion functioned and
every that we can just come in with a
plan and make it run it's it's to my
mind that promethean spirit
is is
part of why it's doomed to fail and it's
doomed to fail in a kind of
terrorizing way
because the promethean spirit
really licenses you
to do anything
because the the ends justify the means
this the end justify the means really
free you to do some of um
basically
um
well commit atrocities at any scale
ground zero with pol pot in the camera
rouge right exactly and you only you can
only believe
in an ends that can justify any means if
you believe in a utopia and you can only
believe in the utopia if you really buy
into the promethean spirit
you